not going very well for the ladies at
the view whoopi goldberg reportedly
threatening to quit after getting
suspended from the show for two weeks
over her comment about the holocaust
whoopi's co-hosts are said to be furious
with the decision here's how the show
very briefly addressed it today
you all saw the news whoopi will be back
here in two weeks
okay
is that how you do it dana well i
haven't
done that
a couple times yes in my career uh look
i i think that's what the
producers must have said yep hit it and
get out and move on and and and that's
what they have to do i i
i don't think i don't know anybody who
is calling for her to be fired that i
know of that i listen to that i follow
but i imagine that inside abc news or
abc excuse me the the outcry amongst the
employees and the staff must have been
high enough that the executive said we
have to do something they felt compelled
that they had to do something the
apology made it worse and so setting
that aside so they make a decision they
suspend her for two weeks she's probably
furious about it she's gonna sit there
and you think she it's like what did
they say we want her to go back and
rethink reflect on it like when your mom
sent you to your room and she's like are
you ready to come out yet and my sister
would always say no i love my room but i
would be mortified i hated to have to be
sent to my room so that's the kind of
punishment that you it's like when
you're a kid that's what you feel what
about you judge do you think she
understands what she did wrong and now
that she's facing suspension she's like
you know what screw it i'm just going to
quit
she may quit i i don't know i don't have
a a hotline to whoopy these days uh
but but but but here's the thing
she doesn't know that she was wrong
she sees it as white race white race all
oppressors and blacks are being are the
victims okay but aside from that the
whole idea of her needing time to
reflect and learn i think is very
important i really do because when you
have anti-semitic behavior a lot of it
is ignorance they don't understand yeah
the enormity she's one of the greatest
hate crimes the world has ever seen and
when i was d.a i took all the da's from
new york state down to the holocaust
museum in washington you want to see
evidence of a hate crime go to the
holocaust museum go to simon wiesenthal
learn about the pain learn what a
swastika does to someone who is a a
survivor of the holocaust i mean they
don't understand it it's just
i can't believe that she has any idea of
the harm that that uh
statement caused a lot of people so
abc's got to be thinking you know could
we cut her loose after two weeks she's
got a hefty salary she could be damaged
goods
got felt what would you do if you were
running abc oh oh man unicorns 24 7
buddy uh this they should be applauding
her this is a historical first for the
view she said remember she said the
holocaust wasn't about race this is the
first time in the views history where
they said something wasn't about race so
i don't know um the if you're looking
for a an analogy that will piss you off
remember how chris harrison got fired
from the bachelor uh except what he said
or did was nothing compared to this
having said that even though she enjoys
liberal privilege it's interesting if
you think about liberal privilege too
much you come to this conclusion
that you have fewer rights
than than liberals do in the world of
free speech there are just things we
can't say because we'll get canned so
there it it's something that people
don't really understand or talk about it
but just think if you at home
change your political ideology to be a
liberal and think about the things that
you could say it opens up a whole new
world it's enticing it is enticing
if you want to sell out yeah let's do it
for one week but she apologized so that
that's what makes us different we're
accepting our apology joy and company
sulked over this even though just a few
days before joy was saying rogan cannot
be reformed and they love getting people
canceled the last thing i want to say is
that she did do a service by
illustrating the kind of the core racist
belief of critical race thinking she did
it by accident the crt cult uh cannot
acknowledge jewish suffering because
that undermines the hierarchy of
oppression the
top of the oppression has to be white
it's just like the food pyramid we're
like the fats is that what's that word
that they use it's trans trans
transsexual trans
transgressing intersectionality yes wow
that was a first for the five
all right harold
it doesn't seem to be like a huge
there's not people outside abc with
signs
oopy must be fired this has to be coming
from the inside i hope i'll say three
quick things i hope that those on the
view and others who have a spouse for
people to be fired and have have really
embraced cancer culture recognize this
is the reason you can't embrace cancer
culture
two i disagree with you judge i think
she realized what she did was wrong and
i think she learned i think whenever you
apologize for something and you're
sincere especially if it has to do with
gender and race and culture and you say
you know what i didn't realize i was
talking about a race that race was
actually a part i'm glad the
anti-defamation league had called her
and explained to her that i actually
believe she was telling the truth there
now
she learned cancel culture has to end
and i hope not only the view but every
show
james carville has said this over and
over again particularly to my party
those progressives in my party and
others who at any slight want to fire
someone not only want to fire them want
to banish them from ever being able to
have a voice or presence again
it should all stop and hopefully maybe
with whoopi's fire whippy's suspension
uh
this is one of the positive things that
comes from it well i consider the fact
that you're so peaceful you're a
peaceful man and and that you like to
think that she is redeemed i don't know
how she got redeemed between stephen
colbert the next morning but what i
think is interesting is that the
co-hosts are furious furious that she
was uh put
on suspension for two weeks you lie
don't you judge because they were so
mean to you on that show they were mean
to me on the show but here's the thing
how do they survive without whoopi yeah
they couldn't even say pre-planned
vacation yeah whoopee goes to cnn
as the new scene i like that i like that
with joe rogan with joe rogan hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else